LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it, and today
we're going to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
with a Googler."
I'm Laurence Moroney,
and today I'm
going to be chatting with
Brian Dorsey, who's a Developer
Advocate on our Cloud team.
And we're going to be talking
a lot about containers.
And if anybody's been in any
way associated with web or cloud
or anything for about
the last 18 months,
containers are
this red-hot topic.
And what's all the fuss?
Can you tell us all about it?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
I think it's definitely
about-- fundamentally
about developer efficiency
and operations efficiency.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
there are a whole bunch
of technical things, like the
packaging and distribution
of the stuff that gets
us there, but really it's
just about letting
you spend more
time on building your
stuff rather than trying
to keep it happy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And like
the two-minute elevator
pitch, what is a container?
What's all the fuss?
BRIAN DORSEY: So it's
implemented on a Linux kernel
and with file system
stuff, a set of APIs
that when used
together, it makes
a nice little encapsulation
for your software.
So you've got a file system
and actually process rights
carved up in a little
box, and so you
can make sure that your
machine, your software,
always runs the same way.
You've probably had
the experience of,
"works on my machine," right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, oh yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: And doesn't--
LAURENCE MORONEY: It doesn't
work on somebody else's, yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: So at
some level, that's
one of the key things
you're solving here,
is that since you have
the exact same file
system, every time
you run it, it
works the same way everywhere.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: And then with
the process level stuff,
you also get really
nice controls
of how much of the processor--
whose processor it can use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you
can keep it-- you know,
if you've got some
Brian code running,
you can keep it from
going a little crazy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Brian code.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
That's a code word for
maybe a little bit rushed.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds good.
Now, it sounds
like when we start
talking about templatizing,
operating systems, and all
this kind of thing that's
for big enterprises
to be able to use, but that's
not really the case, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: So this stuff
is useful at all levels
and, in fact, the big push
18 months to two years ago,
these APIs have been around
Linux for a long time,
but Docker, the company,
wrapped it up very nicely
in a nice UI, made
it very easy to use,
and their focus was very much
on the developer experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
regardless of how big
the eventual end
production size is,
it helps you as a developer run
your stuff more cleanly, help
you collaborate with
other developers,
help you collaborate
with the test folks,
so when you hand
off something, they
get to test the
exact same thing,
and then that same thing
goes into production,
working the same way.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now at Google we
have this Kubernetes software?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
is that all about?
BRIAN DORSEY: So that
comes out of-- you know,
Google's been running
containers internally
for a very long
time, and you may
have heard that the initial
kernel API work was actually
pushed into Linux
kernel, starting
from [INAUDIBLE] to Google.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: So we've got a
bunch of experience doing that,
but it's all built
up internally,
and it's all connected
to our system,
so the Kubernetes Project
is an open source project
to bring those same patterns
out into the whole world.
So we've got-- it's open
source, it's up on GitHub.
It runs on a wide
variety of places.
So you can run Kubernetes
on Compute Engine
and on Google Cloud, but
you can also run it on AWS.
You can run it on
your own computers.
You can run it all
over the place.
And I haven't really
said what it is.
So once you have these
units of a container,
so I've got my one process,
and it runs really well.
What happens when
I want a thousand
of those cooperating with
dozens of some other process
and hundreds of some other
process, and all of a sudden
I've got this-- these are all
running on hundreds of hosts,
maybe.
So this is a big example.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: How do you
keep track of it all?
And so Kubernetes
really helps with that.
That's its core mission,
using these templates
you talked about and things.
But then, as an
individual developer,
if you just are trying to
make a copy of production
that's small enough that you
can actually get it to run,
but it still needs a front
end, a database, cache,
various pieces.
You can spin up just
one of each, small ones,
and have the whole thing up
and working the same way.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Are
there any good examples
of that that are out there,
maybe somebody has documented?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
A little leading.
But we might be thinking
of the same thing.
One of the other Developer
Advocates, Julia Ferraioli,
wrote a really nice post
on-- a series of posts
on using Docker and
Kubernetes to actually run
a "Minecraft" server.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: And "Minecraft"
is this just amazing
block-oriented,
virtual world thing
with lots and lots of plug-ins.
So one of the things
that's challenging
is how do you make sure that
your "Minecraft" world is safe
when you start experimenting
with different plug-ins,
and you want it to roll
forward new versions and back,
and then you want it to
stay running all the time,
because you don't want
to-- like all software,
you don't want to be paged
in the middle of the night
because your "Minecraft"
server's down.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right, and
also, from my understanding,
if you want to build
a "Minecraft" server,
you're not just getting Linux
and MySQL and maybe Apache.
There's all these other things
that you need to install--
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --and
then encapsulate that
and able to clone that
because of containers.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So they've got official
Docker images of all the stuff
"Minecraft" needs to run--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: --and then you
can light that up and go,
and then Kubernetes
gives you the management
of that and networking.
And one way to think
about it, I guess,
is kind of like if you're
familiar with process
runners like systemd,
you get something
like systemd but spread
across a bunch of machines.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
you're like, I want
to make sure 10 copies of this
are always running no matter
what.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
you just hand it off
and then the system actually
keeps that happening.
So instead of just-- you kind
of follow a to-do list maybe,
but at the end you just
hope it keeps working.
In the Kubernetes
world, you say,
I want 10 of these
running always--
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: --and if anything
happens with any of those,
Kubernetes will go and then
start a new one somewhere else,
you know, if a whole
host goes away.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So in summary, it's
almost like the Docker
and the containers
technology is allowing
me to build these easily
replicable machines,
but then Kubernetes adds
on top of that to make
it really easy to manage.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
And assembling them all
together into a real system,
because all systems are
pretty complicated, right?
They kind of grow--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And they're always
more complicated than you
thought they were going to be.
BRIAN DORSEY: Than you
wanted them to be, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
Then trying to replicate
that in other environments,
that's where it really
is very powerful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now how would a developer
get started with all of this?
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
So it does run kind
of anywhere, right?
So you can run on your own
machines, and run it in ABS,
run it in Google Cloud.
Because of some of
the things it does
to make it really easy to
connect these pieces together,
setting up the
networking piece of it
can be a little bit
challenging if you're not
in a cloud environment.
So my recommendation-- maybe
this is a little bit biased,
but definitely the
easiest way to get started
is to use the Google
Cloud free trial,
and there's a one-click startup
for a Kubernetes cluster.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you literally
go down and hit a button
and say, give me a
Kubernetes cluster.
A few minutes later,
you'll have a live cluster
that you can push "Minecraft"
to or your software
or whatever else
you'd like to run.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
BRIAN DORSEY: Also
I think the key
there is separating getting
the cluster up and running
versus running your software on
it, because the new stuff here,
in a way, is really
thinking about building
your software out
of small pieces
and then defining
how those connect
to each other in this
kind of template,
and so that's a really
easy way to play with that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Cool.
BRIAN DORSEY: And then
when you're like, OK,
I want to run it in
this specific place,
you can fiddle with cluster
admin as a separate process
from--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
BRIAN DORSEY: --kind
of running software
in one of these clusters.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So you can really--
getting started
with one button for
Kubernetes, but then you
can really start building
stuff in the Cloud
via "Minecraft" server or
maybe some other kind of server
that you want to run.
I fiddled with the building
3D rendering servers,
and this was precontainers--
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--so every machine
had like a thousand things
that I needed to install,
and then I had to do
it again the next time,
and again the next time.
BRIAN DORSEY: Run a new version.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It drove me crazy.
BRIAN DORSEY: And this is partly
coming from just containers,
but then when you start thinking
about a whole system of these,
it makes upgrading your
system really easy--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY:
--because each version
has the exact pieces it needs.
But the other kind
of magic thing there
that I never achieved
personally is
that I got to where I had
automated upgrades, systems
working.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: But getting it
so you could do a downgrade,
so you could roll back
to a previous version--
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's tricky.
BRIAN DORSEY: --that's harder,
and containers and Kubernetes
together allow you to do that.
It's the exact same process
to roll forward a version
as it is to roll back--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
BRIAN DORSEY: --and you
have this atomic unit.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Cool.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
really exciting.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So developers
get started on the Google Cloud
Console?
BRIAN DORSEY: That's
a great place to go.
The other thing to do
is check kubernetes.io.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: So I'll
give you that link,
and I've got a bunch
of overview information
there, and then a link
to the GitHub site,
where all the active
stuff is going.
And as a developer
perspective, it's really fun,
because there's a huge number
of core people from Google who
built our orchestration stuff
internally, Borg and Omega,
but also a bunch of folks from
Red Hat and [? CORAL-S, ?]
and a bunch of other folks
from the open source community,
a lot of individuals as well.
And so you get to see all of
these people doing code review
and arguing over
design in public.
So if you've ever wondered
how Googlers do code review
or argue, it's a really fun
place to go check it out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So yeah, I
could sell tickets for that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much, Brian.
And thanks, everybody, for
watching this episode of Coffee
with a Googler.
I don't know about you, but I've
learned a lot about containers
and Kubernetes and
managing containers
and how all that works.
If you want to learn
more about this,
check out the links in
the description below.
And if you want to see any
more content around Kubernetes
or any more cloud content,
check out the Google Developers
channel.
If you have any questions for
me or any questions for Brian,
just leave them in
the comments below.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]